hey guys Ryan right here and I'm Jerry
here Ariana
so today we're checking out a video
because I did a reaction video where I
had to leave the room because I was
getting nauseous and people started
calling me a [ __ ] I'm on a binge watch
of a little series I like to call Ryan
Wright proofs he's not a [ __ ] so we're
gonna be watching most disturbing
moments in video games a little montage
I was sent to me by a subscriber haven't
seen it yet
I hope it's super disturbing so I can
show that I'm here Arianna Arianna is
really into violence the k9g section you
don't you're the first person who's come
in with prior knowledge all right here
we go
not even normal you should have hung out
with me I want you to shut up you to
this we were set up we gotta get it out
let's battle years that I've grabbed
over now what are you playing it's a
cinematic without older down
[Music]
let's go get nasi
this is very shiny out there you guys
see some weather Yama is their fake I
hope
I mean this is like disturbing but in a
way like watching watching a medical
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's a name that's happened that's when
we crawl into this experience such as a
cleric saw
[Music]
[Applause]
remember this you are getting music
production this thing don't you will
clean these things well these are like
beautiful
they're like the scenes that advances
there must be another way Oh drill is I
started to watch more violence of my
life
[Music]
then keep pressing in it
[Music]
we press X enough times o GTA baby
[Music]
Ariana's into this kinda stuff I'm over
I know I'm not scared about it anymore
alright let's just see what happens
[Music]
that's just a present why
damn you brought this on yourself
we were helping I've been in this exact
situation oh no that guy looks like Jana
Jana
yeah when I went to Denny's
[Music]
[Music]
come on man I want to see some blood
are those civilians
where they come from there's no camp
here mark already took him from the nest
that'll tell back at the storm walk no
no no those can't be the cities that got
kidnapped they have a much possible
such a kidnapped hopes for this person
and what the king
[Music]
here we go finally chops of enough
[Music]
pressed where
do it Presley left woman don't be a
[ __ ]
man up man up do it that is what this
problem
one slice no one can be doctor come on
keep going man keep going dude being a
[ __ ] this would be better if I knew the
context right like why didn't you go and
solve your finger yeah honestly guts
thing was the work yeah it started off
like okay this is gonna escalate was
okay I mean there was some cruelty yeah
after a while it was like I could see
how this is disturbing but not like
gross out like that's what I wanted is
like pure violence just watch that they
just gave us like they just gave us like
really good dramatic game scenes who
cares about that
no yeah I want blood and gore those are
the scenes you put skip right yeah you
just who [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] about story I
was joking guys know a lot of your
gamers she clearly is too right anyway
yeah I just wanted to continue my little
journey here and I brought Jerry and
Ariana along for the trip so with that
conclusion if you guys are new to the
channel if you oh Jesus
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects chieri
has a playlist on this channel reasons
to jer-bear and he can follow
Ariana's channel and she's gonna be
putting a video soon so subscribe now
you bought us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where we are hoping to get
product placement for for for miss pumps
penis pumps yeah penis pumps it's not
like in Magic Mike yeah yeah yeah
Ariana is usually disappointed with the
size of men so she brings a penis pump
with her everywhere she goes
ready for them to deal with you like how
to counter these things you deal with a
penis pump everywhere next time you're
in here you get up and I'm like yeah you
got a train
she likes gaming you know - when she's
doing it I'll train you
I'm like no every time I'm like no I
don't it's not strong enough no no
that's okay we'll have ones Rocky like
montages right yeah like sidelines what
you like you're such a [ __ ] and I'm like
yeah sweetie come back while I carry a
log up a hill she does like to have come
on her back yet this is Ariana eating my
sweat this is the final footage of
Ariana Bell Suri before what where she
goes to her gaming